[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's
ofenkartoffeln mit knoblauch und ich
habe mir gedacht das ist erstens die
perfekte grill beilage zweitens aber
auch einfach nur eine beilage zum
mittagessen oder drittens einfach nur
ein snack wenn ihr mal wieder kohldampf
habt und jetzt darf ich auch direkt ich
habe jetzt hier meine kartoffeln die
habe mich geschämt und gewaschen und
wird sie jetzt schneiden in grobe stücke
ich möchte sie nicht so klein war dann
ruhig ein bisschen größer aber dass es
komplett euch überlassen so die
kartoffeln jetzt einfach direkt aufs
backblech geben und dann kommt da
olivenöl dazu nimmt ein gutes
kaltgepresstes und kartoffeln mit
olivenöl es sowieso immer mega lecker
und dann gebe ich da auch noch salz dazu
am besten direkt aus der mühle so und
damit den händen schild verteilen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt knoblauch zum einsatz
knoblauch passt ja immer mega mega gut
und diesmal machen wir so wir nehmen uns
einen ganzen bund knoblauch schneiden
das hier vorne ab und haben wir eine
schnittfläche so die denke ich jetzt
einmal in etwas olivenöl und dann nimmt
ihr euch einfach backpapier einmal unter
wasser halten ausbringen jetzt ist es
schön feucht und dann wickel ich hier
dieses bund knoblauch einmal nach rein
schön und wickeln das brauchen wir auch
nachher noch wenn es mit dem ofen
richtig schön weich so und das gebe ich
jetzt hier einfach in die mitte des bak
place und jetzt habe ich auch schon den
ofen vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober
unterhitze und dann wird das je nach
größe wie groß das jetzt geschnitten hat
ungefähr 40 bis 50 minuten gar gebacken
und dann sehen wir uns nachher wieder
[Musik]
nach dem backen schnappen wir uns jetzt
ein mörser oder ein fein mixa und geben
der frische petersilie rein und außerdem
die knoblauchzehen die jetzt richtig
schön weich geworden sind im backofen
und gerichts auch schon richtig nach
knoblauch so den börsen der das schön
fein und geben anschließend creme
fraiche oder zum beispiel saure sahne
oder joghurt dazu und dann ist unser
tipp dazu auch schon fertig das heißt er
hat die quasi 2 1 1 und könnte jetzt
einfach genießen die schnappen jetzt
hier so eine schöne kartoffel und gibt
es hier einmal rein dann probiere ich
auch gerne einmal für euch mal das auch
super lecker ist richtig knusprig und
köstlich also macht es unbedingt nach
ihr könnt auch gerne den kanal kostenlos
abonnieren damit ihnen nichts mehr
verpasst und dann sehen wir uns nun ganz
bald wieder hier auf meinem kanal lassen
uns gerne in den kommentaren miteinander
schreiben
und ja bis zum nächsten mal hier auf
dieses kitchen chilis
[Musik]
noch nicht mal